be honest all i wanted to do is play
qriket and play cricket for england
and
live my dream and live my family's dream
in my first spell i don't really think i
quite
realized for what it was
i think i was in denial
i looked the other way just like
everyone else did because
really for me um playing qriket was the
most important thing
towards the end of my first spell um
but constantly throughout it i knew
there was something wrong but i didn't
quite i couldn't quite put my finger on
what was wrong i started taking
medication from my mental health
and um it was tough really tough
i left the club in 2014 um i tried
instead of looking at them things i went
away and tried to work on myself my game
and my mental health
i felt like i did that
and then i got an opportunity um
through my performances being above and
beyond everyone else to um get back at
the club and because they struggled to
replace me quite frankly
i don't know she had gone to play for
england and they couldn't replace me um
the first few months i came back i
thought you know what things have
changed here
it's a little bit different alex lee's
was a captain
who was a friend and uh quite um well
he's a good person and i know he had
personal tragedies of himself at a young
age so
he understood me um with jason gillespie
the australian cricketer and coach
who i felt supported
by jason left the end of 2016 and it
just felt wow the temperature in the
room had just been turned up
you got andrew gill coming in as coach
and gary balance as captain
and these guys
for me they were in yorkshire through
and through and they
as they call it the white rose values
were embedded in them
for the first time
i started to see for what it was
felt isolated
humiliated at times a couple of men were
beard and it was like oh is that your
dad if we go past a corner shop or does
your uncle own this and this happened in
front of again
martin oxen andrew gale club officials
and it would never got stamped out
everyone saw it
but because the institution and the
environment it becomes such a norm in
there that um
i don't think anyone thought there was
anything wrong with it and that's
probably why some people don't even
remember it